لقد حملت للتو
كيسًا هوائيًا للوجبات الخفيفة بينما حقيبتك نفسها يمكن أن تكون
كيس رقائق بطاطس ، أظهر Balenciaga
عارضين يمسكون بحقيبة الرقائق
[موسيقى]
في عرض الطين المزعوم في وقت سابق من هذا
الشهر في باريس ، لكن هذه الحقيبة
بالتأكيد ليست رخيصة الأوساخ  وهذه
الحقيبة ستذهب مقابل ثمانمائة دولار
لكنها ستكون مصنوعة من جلد العجل
ولها سحاب يقال إن
1800 دولار من الرقائق غير متضمنة شخص
مزاح في Balenciaga ، كلكم يأخذون
طوابع الطعام ، وستأتي الحقيبة بأربع نكهات
وهذا هو نفسه  منزل التصميم الراقي
الذي صنع كيس القمامة أيضًا من
جلد العجل والذي يكلف أيضًا
ثمانمائة دولار أمريكي بالطبع إنه أزياء
مثيرة ومصمم المشاهير Philip
Block ، كل هذا يشبه الانتباه
لاحظني كثيرًا أنهم شاهدوا كيسًا مشابهًا
في قماش على قماش.  موقع التجارة الإلكترونية
AliExpress الذي يبيع بسعر 3.86
، تبدو الحقيبة التي يبلغ ثمنها ثمانية عشرمائة دولارًا
وكأنها حقيبة بثلاثة دولارات تبدو وكأنها
حقيبة من الرقائق بقيمة دولارين ، سأحصل على
الرقائق ناهيك عن رقاقة جلدية.
يفتقر g إلى هذا التجعد المميز
الذي أقول إنه حدث هناك حتى أنني ارتديت
بدلة كاملة مصنوعة من أكياس رقائق معروضة
في معرض فني تقريبًا مثل
كيس القمامة في المطر ولكن كان ذلك
منذ 25 عامًا تقريبًا حتى في ذلك الوقت كان
دافئًا مثلي  لقد كان لدينا الكثير من
رقائق البطاطس منذ ذلك الحين لتتناسب مع ذلك
مرة أخرى رقائق البطاطس ولكن يمكنك أن تأكل
واحدة ولكن في Balenciaga أراهن أنه لا يمكنك
شراء واحدة فقط مقابل ثمانمائة دولار ،
فهذه الوجبات باهظة الثمن للغاية ، لذا فأنت
تحتاج عمليًا إلى وضع
CNN  نيويورك